i couldn't sleep last night i was
thinking about if um this is so
random if uh i've been listening this uh
documentary on hitler
dude if they would have just given him a
scholarship for his art this vienna
school of the art so many people would
be
[ __ ] scared he didn't get into the
vienna school and then he had hatred in
his heart and that's when he went went
back do you know why
same thing if charles manson just got
that [ __ ] record deal do you know why
six people didn't get in he couldn't
draw human figures he was really good at
drawing buildings and stuff have you
seen someone's drawing
sucked at drawing human figures have you
seen someone's drawing yes pretty
[ __ ] legitimate
i was like how did he not get in yeah
again yeah he was bad at drawing human
figures bad at drawing human figures
did you know he erased all his past when
he became the fuhrer
because he was pretty average in
everything but he wanted people to look
at him like a god
so any of the stuff before he's a fear
was all erased
that's the cult of personality that's
great they want you to think he's this
higher b
any any tyrant rewrites history and and
changes the truth
those are nice flowers now i'm not
hanging out in my
living room veggies oh what piece is
that hitler yep vegetarian
uh and also uh how about this wouldn't
hurt
animals because vegetarian didn't
believe in eating animals but
tortured and killed many many humans
yeah dude if that teacher could have
just
let him let him in [ __ ] art school
let him in i'm sure he wasn't the worst
it's same with charles manson god damn
it give him a record deal give him the
record deal
sharon tate's alive right now diamond
piece yeah
but where does just those little things
historians obsess over those little
details historians are like if you had
if you had just gotten if you had just
been an
artist but he was he was basically an
incel
he was basically well there was a guy
who was like
salad is a whole life old older german
guy and he goes yeah i met hitler
there's nothing special
no like he met him like when he was like
in the thing he said the same thing
about stalin
stalin was was a was a bureaucrat who
kept himself
even his ambitions kind of very kind of
under
you know he wasn't he was not you never
really described him as anything
nothing special no it was like it was a
bunch of guys and they always they
always have signs that
they're the they're calling like hitler
was in world war
one right and he was in the foxhole and
a bomb
came and he said something told him to
walk over here we'll probably have to
take a piss
so he walks over the devil was like yeah
what
maybe but i think probably had to take a
piss or [ __ ] so he walks over there
bomb comes blows up his buddy he goes
this is a sign i should be the leader of
germany
yeah i guess dude when they take a hot
piss and your buddies just stayed there
if you read about world war one
i've never read an account where it
wasn't hell on earth
you were in trenches the rain would come
you know where it was
and you have to you had to go to the
bathroom there and then bodies would be
there so you'd be living
in a ditch with water with dead bodies
and
feces and you couldn't get clean people
would cry because they couldn't get
clean
and then you just didn't know if you're
going to die and then it wouldn't rain
mustard gas would come over it would
settle in the water so you couldn't
drink any water so people would die of
the whole thing with the knife hitler's
yeah he sealed he got hit with mustard
yes and he went blind and then he found
that germany had had surrendered he was
like
what he got pissed he seemed to
according to his superior
charisma though beaches oh my god he was
very happy yeah
yeah have you heard some of his speeches
that's how you win people over like his
charisma especially at a time with
the the germans were going through
horrible horrible times
so he was good at marketing his charisma
is so good
as a leader does unfortunately and he
just happened to be a terrible person
but you think obama charisma trump
charisma
like the leaders the best leaders have
that criticism listen to they can speak
to the people
and jeremy at the time you're talking
about a horrible time in in their
existence
and then he goes the jews are the
problem why we're upset and then he
paints this narrative of
why they're evil and they're the reason
why we're doing so bad and people go
damn he's kind of right and that and
there you go that's how it goes
and he seemed to enjoy world war one
he's the only person that's ever said i
i he liked it this was a total sociopath
but he could
speak if you see him speak when he would
start giving his speeches it was [ __ ]
drenched in sweat unbelievable like
passionate
i mean no one speaks german but you just
from it you can see it the past if you
were an actor
he's better actor than like he was an
amazing actress daniel day lewis yeah
daniel davis probably hates that
computer somebody you see what i'm
saying what's the passion when he's
talking about deutschland uber alice
deutschland over germany overall
look at this the top one yeah watch
watch the way he speaks
their outfits were fire by the arbeit
fury decades
at a time of desperation so you have
this guy coming telling you things you
want to hear
like oh this is not going to come look
at this [ __ ] watch this
watch this [ __ ] look at all the
people and
what this is i think this might be the
most famous squash
look at the look at the he came up with
that the swastika
thousand pairs of boots standing heel to
heel look at this waiting for the
fuhrer's final speed
and the high spot comes when after a
detailed review of nazi achievements
hitler cries
my life's fight has not been in vain
i'd feel gay if i could lose unity
[Applause]
yeah you really wonder if a guy like
that had some kind of
like people have said the devil the
devil was sort of like
you know he tapped into some dark
[ __ ] art or something
which i don't believe i think your
mission is sociopath what's that
you just had a mission with a sociopath
it's one of those crazy
good timing the camera the economy was
you know there's a big
perfect in a society that followed my
authority blindly yes
you know that was very very disciplined
and very you have a leader like that
and whatever you're spewing you're
buying